the movie opens up with a woman named
Kira mabon who is dating yonas stinski
after an enjoyable evening at a bar he
takes her to his place where they spend
the night together when Kira wakes up
the next morning Jonas is already gone
and her attempts to contact him are
unsuccessful nevertheless she leaves the
apartment without a care in the world on
the way she calls her friend Martha to
recount the evening with her fifth date
however her friend abruptly hangs up on
her implying doubt about Kira's account
it's one jealous ass friend just then
Kira realizes that she has inexplicably
walked back to Jonas's building in a
confused State she enters the apartment
which has become different from the one
she's just left and it feels strangely
familiar she recognizes the furniture
and several other things as if she has
been there long ago she also has a
vision of a little girl playing in one
of the rooms she frantically calls the
contact labeled home and to her surprise
the landline rings in the same apartment
all of this seems to tell Kira that this
is her home the only sign of Jonas is an
old photograph of him and and Kira
together which appears to be very old
unable to comprehend the situation Kira
rushes to the washroom where she notices
that one of her fingers skin is
crumbling off as she tries to tear them
off it starts bleeding which makes her
uneasy so she patches it again shortly
after she hears a knock on the door and
sees Martha through the peephole but
before she can open the door she
collapses to the ground due to
excruciating pain in her finger by the
time she regains her Consciousness she
finds that her friend has already gone
right there then Kira meets her neighbor
Sophia demaro who invites her to her
place Kira appears to be meeting her for
the first time but by the way Sophia
talks it seems that she knows her from a
long time ago puzzled Kira wonders how
she knows her and Sophia reveals that
they have been neighbors for quite some
time now as their conversation unfolds
Kira shows her the picture of Jonas and
asks if she knows him however the latter
doesn't seem to recognize him and
attributes the picture to being very old
following this Kira returns back to her
apartment and takes some time to make
sense of the situation she probably look
in a mirror Kira later that evening
Sophia comes back to Kira expressing
concern for her well-being and
recommending a visit to the doctor in
response Kira mentions having a doctor's
appointment letter but is uncertain
about the date of her last visit Sophia
helps her with some comforting words
that eventually lifts up her mood the
two then share a toast with a glass of
wine during this Kira's glass slips from
her hand and Falls shattering it into
pieces to make matters worse Sophia
accidentally steps on the broken pieces
causing a small cut on her foot Kira
then gathers the broken glass and a
piece of Sophia's skin before heading to
the bathroom there she gently replaces
her finger's skin with that of the skin
from Sophia's foot to her surprise
Sophia's skin quickly melds with hers
this makes her believe that she has
finally discovered a cure by swapping
out her flaky skin with healthier skin
she can achieve smooth and rejuvenated
skin the following morning Kira wakes up
to learn that her skin infection is
spread even more as a result she decides
to seek medic medical help and meets Dr
raphaela crober Who carefully extracts a
sample of her flaky skin for testing
curious Kira asks if she has been here
before but the doctor dismisses it as an
unimportant topic after some time Dr
raphaela reveals that Kira skin is
undergoing atypical cell deterioration
indicating premature aging thank God
says Kira I thought I had that Benjamin
Button [__] hearing this though Kira
asks about the possibility of a skin
transplant but the doctor advises
waiting for the test results before
making a decision Dr raphaelo also
provides her with some medications to
cope with the pain and assures that it
will get cured afterwards Kira finds out
that the skin condition has extended to
her shoulder unable to wait for the test
result she decides to visit another
hospital while waiting for the doctor
she notices a mortician taking a smooth
skinned dead body towards the mor Grom
Kira appears to be envious of the dead
body skin as well shortly after Dr CER
examines her and suggests that she can
salt with skin Specialists or maybe just
skin some dead people with no immediate
treatment Kira exits the office feeling
despondent just then an idea strikes her
leading her to sneak into the morg once
in there she uses a scalpel to cut a
piece of skin from a lifeless body she
then attempts to cover her wound on the
shoulder unfortunately the skin from the
deceased body lacks the expected healing
power it doesn't adhere with her own
skin at this moment Kira understands
that only fresh skin has an impact on
her flaky skin afterwards Kira is able
to endure the pain so she resorts to
calling Dr raphaela Desperately Seeking
help however the doctor can only
recommend staying calm getting some rest
and taking the prescribed medicine Kira
then walks into a bar intending to
counter her pain with a drink while
there her attention is grabbed by a
waitress with smooth skin overwhelmed by
jealousy Kira follows the waitress to
the basement where she knocks her
unconscious removes a piece of skin from
her shoulder and places it on her flaky
skin and this time this the Skin Blends
seamlessly just the way it did before as
if waitresses didn't already have it bad
enough in the aftermath Kira brings the
unconscious waitress to her home
intending to complete the entire process
overnight as Kira Revels in the
sensation of smooth skin the waitress
regains her Consciousness she tries to
scream for help but before that Kira
quickly covers her mouth and stabs her
in the neck resulting in her death she
then slowly removes her flaky skin and
replaces it with the freshly acquired
skin from the waitress later Kira is
thrilled to observe the smooth and
impeccable condition of her new skin
while admiring herself in the mirror she
notices a spot on her shoulder starting
to flake again just then Sophia pays her
a visit and admires her smooth and
Flawless skin she also expresses her
Curiosity on the treatment for such an
outcome but Kira evades the truth simply
pretending that it was medication
prescribed by the doctor it's just
elephant jizz works wonders their
conversation eventually takes a romantic
turn probably because she said elephant
jizz and then they end up getting
intimate the next day Kira visits Dr
raphaela as the test results are finally
out however the doctor adds that it will
take a few more days to establish the
precise treatment plan she also
emphasizes that the hospital needs to
make a reminder call since Kira is
having some problem with her memory
despite this Kira doesn't show much
concern about it the same evening she
and Sophia spend some private time
together when the ladder once again asks
about skin treatment Kira gets irritated
and storms out of the room I already
told you the jizz is from Nepal it's
totally sustainable later on she notices
that her flaky skin has started to
spread across her entire body one night
at a bar Kira spots another woman with
flawless skin and follows her to the
restroom there she commits another
murder in order to obtain her skin after
a swift skin replacement process she
leaves the bar unnoticed meanwhile
Sophia catches up with her on the way
attempting to apologize but Kira insists
on being left alone back home Kira Weeps
burdened By guilt overt taking innocent
lives furthermore she is also disturbed
by constant flashbacks of the time she
spent with Jonas she rushes to the
bathroom to calm herself down but much
to her dismay she sees herself as an old
woman in the mirror told you this sets
her into a panic for a moment but she
notices the police arresting someone
else allowing her to breathe a sigh of
relief afterwards Sophia visits her and
this time Kira welcomes her in while
Sophia is busy enjoying the music Kira
slips into the bathroom to check on the
girl she appears to have kidnapped she
then rejoins Sophia and asks her to
check her body for any signs of flaky
skin on the back upon doing so Sophia
notices some flaky skin and she
recommends revisiting the doctor once
she departs Kira proceeds to replace her
skin with that of the kidnapped girls
later in the clinic Dr raphaela informs
Kira that they finally discovered a cure
to rejuvenate her skin potentially
slowing down its Decay this news brings
great joy to Kira's face regardless the
doctor still asks for more time for a
thorough research of the procedure
unwilling to wait any longer Kira breaks
into the office and steals the treatment
plan by the time she returns home the
kidnapped girl seems to have managed to
drag herself to the door however Kira
again drags her back to the bathroom now
that the floor is stained with blood
Kira begins to clean it afterwards she
goes to Sophia's place along with the
stolen documents and the two proceed to
watch it together the video depicts a
woman in her 60s who is willing to
participate in an experimental procedure
to reverse aging at the end of the video
the elderly woman ultimately transforms
into a younger version here it is
revealed that this woman is none other
than Kira herself we also learn that she
got divorced from Jonas 20 years ago
after giving birth to a daughter a fact
that she is still unable to recall this
Revelation unsettles her deeply now that
her skin is aging faster she doesn't
know how to face the rest of her life
strangely enough Sophia doesn't look
surprised by all of this and she instead
Comforts her by assuring that she will
always be by her side desperate to
unravel the complete truth Kira contacts
her daughter who is now an adult woman
she becomes speechless upon learning
that her daughter now has a child of her
own unable to digest all of these
Revelations Kira wishes to run far away
to some place where nobody recognizes
her Sophia decides to accompany her and
starts packing up her things before they
depart Kira douses her entire room with
gasoline and sets it a blaze erasing all
remnants of her family memories once out
of the apartment Kira and Sophia attempt
to find more volunteers for the reverse
aging experiment but they are unable to
locate any following this Kira decides
to visit her daughter's house upon
arrival a little girl presumably her
granddaughter answers the door the two
have a brief conversation until the
little girl screams upon seeing Kira's
flaking skin guess got to get some head
and shoulders [__] as a result she
hastily departs from the place being
unable to confront her daughter after
this Kira and Sophia stay at a motel and
by this time Kira's skin condition
begins to worsen seeing this Sophia
advises her to see Dr raphaela but the
latter ref fuses it is at this point
that Sophia confesses the truth her
background in Biochemistry and her
collaboration with Dr raphaela in
monitoring Kira she also reveals a
sedative in Kira's water which knocks
the ladder out in the next scene Kira
wakes up restrained on a lab table
shortly after Dr raphaela approaches her
and expresses her regret acknowledging
that test subjects should never have
been let out of the lab she also
explains that Kira's missing memories
are a side effect of the Regeneration
process in an attempt to figure out how
Akira's skin flawlessly merged with
foreign tissue Dr raphaela initiates
painful experiments that continue for
several days witnessing her partner
suffering Sophia becomes furious at the
doctor and proceeds to release her in
order to stop her from doing so Dr
raphaela injects a substance into
Sophia's neck despite this she somehow
continues to fight back earning time for
Kira to recover soon after Kira grabs a
metal container and knocks down the
doctor before choking her to death she
then tries to exchange her skin skin
with that of the doctors but Sophia
stops her from doing so she doesn't want
Kira to commit another crime so she
makes her promise to refrain from
further skin replacement procedures as
the effect of injection kicks in
Sophia's state begins to worsen seeing
this Kira makes a brave move she
eliminates several medical personnel
retrieves a gun from one of them and
ventures in search of an antidote for
Sophia in a room Kira comes across a
young nurse and seeing her beautiful
skin she can't control her urges later
when she returns to her partner Sophia
learns that she has again killed someone
evident by her smooth skin smooth as
eggs realizing that she has become a
huge threat for people Sophia kisses her
for one last time before shooting her to
death subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching